c'est pas possible je peux pas y croire
[Musique]
nous vous invitons à suivre cette
jeunesse en plein cœur de Paris au club
du Golfe Drouot nous avons pu installer
nos caméras en essayant de ne pas trahir
cette ambiance ah je tendre et tête de
bois
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
avec l'animateur du golf Henri qui va
nous raconter l'histoire de ces lieux ah
oui alors maintenant nous n'avons plus
de golf à propos
d'ailleurs c'est des bowling qui les
remplacent et il y avait ici l'an
dernier un superbe piano mécanique oui
mais maintenant c'est le jukebox qui l'a
dépassé
et alors parmi les enfants du golf il y
a des jeunes qui se sont fait un non
tout de même
d'ailleurs ils sont parmi nous
délibrées debout libre
Sylvie Vartan
Dany pisser
des chaussettes noires tout ça ce sont
des enfants du golf mais vous oubliez le
plus célèbre voyons je le dis tout de
suite c'est la volette surprise moi j'ai
l'impression je vous l'annonce tout de
suite c'est Johnny Hallyday
[Applaudissements]
allez j'en m'appelle les Dolls des
jeunes il en est même qui
m'envie mais il ne savent pas dans la
vie
que parfois je m'ennuie là dernièrement
tu as lancé une nouvelle danse enfin tu
la lance en ce moment et je crois que
c'est la première fois qu'on la verra à
la télévision c'est le c'est le match
potatos ça veut dire match purée de
pommes de terre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ceux qui aiment sa vienne ce qui n'aime
pas ça ne vienne pas étudiants il y a
des ouvriers les employés je crois qu'il
y a un peu de tout oui c'est très
mélange oui je crois comment il est bien
ici c'est très jeune c'est à dire très
jeune pour vous 18 20 ans en général pas
de plus mais il arrive je suppose que
des personnes qui ont des attentes
[Musique]
dans un dans des cafés ils écoutent du
box et vous voyez ce que je veux dire
non par exactement qu'est-ce que vous
appelez ce genre de garçon vous ne
fréquentez pas vous pourquoi parce que
c'est pas les fréquences
et voilà c'est danseurs de rock'n'roll
dont on attend parler ces fameuses
admirateurs de Johnny Hallyday dont les
rencontres provoquent des bagarres
retentissants alors eux que vont-ils
répondre à ce qui traite le rock avec
Tom mépris je suis arrivé dans
l'établissement et puis c'est la
clientèle qui est venue jeune et à
chasser les plus âgés ils sont vraiment
terribles
ils sont pas plus méchants qu'avant
seulement ils sont plus nerveux plus ni
revenus davantage ils ont plus de
facilité aussi mais je crois que vous
leur interdisez un certain nombre de
choses ou même la punition c'est de leur
interdire l'accès de l'établissement et
comme tous les camarades leur service
viennent régulièrement ça c'est
qu'est-ce qui leur vaut qu'on leur
interdisent l'accès de l'établissement
par exemple ça arrive souvent le moins
possible mais parce qu'on les freine dès
qu'il y en a un qui s'est battu n'a plus
le droit de revenir ils ont droit au jus
de fruits ils ont droit qu'au jus de
fruits l'alcool quels sont vos rapports
avec les jeunes filles qui viennent ici
au camaraderie ou fleurent fleur oui et
vous mademoiselle on est souvent un peu
trop
[Musique]
dimanche après-midi
ils sont d'accord ils sont d'accord que
vous aimiez aussi souvent
on en a l'habitude alors au début c'est
impressionne mais après plus du tout
qu'est-ce qu'il y a de beaux garçons
selon vous parmi vos camarades ici
et vous qu'est-ce que vous pensez de la
façon dont il est habillé ah ben moi
j'aime beaucoup cette espèce de laisser
aller j'aime assez est-ce qu'il y a un
style golf
oh oui je crois comment le
définissez-vous
[Musique]
dernière crise
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je vous invite à venir vous retrouver
avec moi justement
[Musique]
si vous le voulez bien découvrons avec
Patrick ce temple du rock n' roll qui
est le golf de Rouault première surprise
vous voyez on ne descend pas dans la
boîte contrairement à ce qu'a dit
Patrick on y monte madame vous avez la
caissière j'aimerais savoir combien de
personnes arrivent par soient réussi
environ 2 à 3 sonne à la fois mais il y
en a plus car la clientèle se partage
ceux qui prennent le dernier métro et
ceux qui prendront le premier à 5h30 du
matin ça veut dire que ceux qui prennent
le premier métro reste ici jusqu'à
partir vous savez des fois il fait froid
5h30 c'est l'hiver ils sont bien ici ils
ont pas du tout envie de partir est-ce
qu'il y a plus de filles que de garçons
ça dépend des soirées ça dépend des
soirs le vendredi est plutôt réservé aux
musiciens et là il a peut-être plus de
garçons mais il y a quand même beaucoup
de jeunes filles le samedi soir le
dimanche après-midi
pourquoi viens-tu au golfro parce qu'il
y a une ambiance assez sympa et des
contrats c'est que j'aime bien écouter
de la musique et m'amuser un peu
tranquille
et puis parce qu'en ce moment il y a
tremplin d'or et que c'est intéressant
de voir un peu les groupes comment ça
évolue en France alors une fois de temps
en temps je réapparaît au golf
d'où viens-tu j'habite à Paris
travaille actuellement oui oui je
m'occupe d'enfant pourquoi
des amis pour écouter un peu de musique
parce que c'est la seule la seule boîte
dans Paris ou il y a ce style de musique
disons que c'est un endroit où on peut
retrouver certains amis
que dans Paris il y a rien d'autre
[Musique]
monsieur le prouve vous êtes le manager
oui je suis le créateur le directeur
l'animateur qui met du Gordon je vous
demande de faire de tracer le brièvement
l'historique du canton bien vous savez
quand je suis arrivé en 1955 c'était un
golf miniature il y avait très peu de
clients et j'ai pensé qu'il fallait
créer un club réservé uniquement au
moins de 20 ans il y en avait pas à
l'époque il y avait surtout des
discothèques qui étaient réservés au
Tout-Paris
on a eu dès le départ des jeunes qui se
passionnaient pour le rock'n'roll donc
on a été les premiers à diffuser dans le
jukebox à l'époque les premiers Bill
Haley Elvis Presley et ensuite des
jeunes auteurs compositeurs sont venus
avec leurs guitare pour chanter devant
la clientèle du golf et parmi elles il y
a eu des beaucoup de jeunes que j'ai
présenté par la suite des producteurs à
des maisons de disques et ils sont
devenus très célèbres on écoute
régulièrement tous les vendredis sur le
tremplin des orchestres qui de tous les
coins de France et même des fois de
l'étranger ils passent devant mon public
et devant des directeurs artistiques qui
sont susceptibles de les produire par la
suite
et 20 ans le goldro a vu de 4000
orchestres et des jeunes qui viennent
qui sont est-ce qu'il y a un type il y a
oui c'est une c'est un peu la communauté
c'est son que des jeunes qui se
passionnent pour la musique ce n'est pas
un dancing c'est pas une boîte de nuit
ni un cabaret c'est un peu un festival
pop permanent pour pour les moins de 20
ans
ça va Gilou
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour pour
[Musique]
qui peut faire une suite à votre
carrière
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
que pensez-vous qu'ils ressent j'espère
qu'elles sont devenus
plein de choses
[Musique]
dans le cadre
le golf droule le temple du rock'n'roll
c'est fini ainsi on a décidé la justice
depuis trois ans la société propriétaire
avait déjà été condamné deux fois parce
que l'exploitait au même endroit deux
débits de boissons la société c'est
pourvu en cassation mais elle n'a pas
obtenu gain de cause c'était donc
aujourd'hui la dernière au Golf Drouot
patrice Drevet y assistait pour nous
le golfe Drouot c'est le temple du rock
n' roll parisien depuis 27 ans plus de 2
millions de jeunes sont venus encourager
ou sortir quelques 7000 orchestres qui
se sont produits sur le célèbre tremplin
du samedi soir
[Musique]
dans les années 60 elles sont toutes
passées par le golfe les idoles du yéyé
Johnny et dit chez la Sylvie et les
autres
[Musique]
c'était Johnny c'était dit c'était du
tronc ils sont tous nés dans le 9e
arrondissement comme le golfe Drôme et
nous avions un juke-box alors on se
procurer les premiers disques de Bill
Haley de presled de gin Vincent et
ensuite ces jeunes ont voulu chanter
comme comme les
idoles américaines et Johnny a commencé
à enregistrer il a vendu du disque
ensuite les maisons de 10 on veut se
sont précipités au golf pour retrouver
justement d'autres jeunes susceptibles
de d'être enregistré et ça a été
l'arrivée des chaussettes noires des
chats sauvages des aristocrates enfin
toutes les pop du yéyé
[Musique]
je pense que je vais faire la semaine
prochaine par exemple parce que Michel
Drucker je peux pas supporter le
dimanche après-midi
[Musique]
c'est quoi tu es désemparé tu es triste
je suis très triste
alors voilà c'est fini nous avons filmé
les derniers pas des danseurs de rock
étrangement habillé comme il y a 27 ans
dans ce même golf de roue
[Musique]